[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today gen Z
doesn't agree that $74,000 is middle
class no kidding it's not even close
check this out if you take $74,000 for a
genen z or let's say they have a
bachelor's degree and they're 25 years
old first of all 74,000 is much higher
than the average income most geners are
probably making anywhere from 40 to 50
maybe 60 but let's use 74 the take-home
after taxes 401k and health insurance is
$4,300 the average college monthly
payment on Al loans about 500 bucks
you're down to 3,800 let's say this
person is financially responsible
decides to split a two-bedroom apartment
in a medium-sized City like Orlando so
that their payment is 1,200 a piece 200
for utility so 1,400 now unless they're
going to have Lucky Charms and peut
butter and jelly their groceries are
going to cost about 600 bucks if they're
trying to get chicken beef and some
healthy stuff you have a $400 car
payment $200 Insurance $150 for gas $100
for a cell phone leaves you with 950
bucks this is no savings investment no
emergency fund let's give them at least
300 to go on a couple dates or hang out
with their friends for the month so they
can enjoy life a little bit they're left
with only
$650 a bachelor's degree 74k salary you
are splitting a two-bedroom apartment
with a friend and only have $650 left a
month it would take you years to save up
the 30,000 that you would need for a
down payment on a house with the closing
cost but even if you could get that down
payment saved you would still need to
make
$120,000 a year to be considered for a
$400,000 loan the middle class the goal
post has been moved from 70k to
$120,000 in just the past 2
years okay okay uh I got some thoughts
Rachel Cruz I did too you go Jade um
number one when my guy said only $650
left there were a couple of things that
are screaming at me a only $650 left I
think that if you're just starting out
you're in your
20s I'm like yeah that's that if you're
22 years old and you have $650,000 left
over come on somebody number two pretty
good that's good then I'm like okay I'm
just getting into $300 on fund money
again that's a lot of money like that
ain't bad I'm can I be 100% real talk
yeah on my budget right now where it
says Jade fund money it's
$300 and I'm telling you I make more
than $74,000 a year so okay okay and
then so then add in which is normal I
get but what if you decided to get an
extra job and pay off this debt you
would free up a car payment $400 and
free up $500 student loans so that's
$900 $600 for groceries for a single
person I think you can do it at 500 so
that's an extra hundred that you pick
out so so there's an extra thousand so
that's really $6
$600 extra uh yeah I think I think we're
okay I think this is an
expectation conversation yes yes and
we're not going to make $74,000 forever
ever amen no or no $40,000 forever and
ever and amen or whatever it is right as
you get older and you work you will be
making more money over your lifetime
that is true I I just I this really
rubbed me the wrong way Rachel I just I
think that like what you said this is
all expectation and it's kind of tunnel
vision and getting caught in the now you
know it's like you're looking at
everything that you're seeing on social
media and you're creating this bar of
what you should have you're even looking
at maybe what friends and family members
have like so many people they come out
of their parents' house and you've been
living in this environment where there's
um nicer cars the the home is larger um
and you immediately kind of feel like oh
yeah I'm supposed to have that too and
I'm like listen these things take time
it took time for our parents to get
where they are if that's what you're
comparing it to yeah and and we'll say
this I'll say this number one has life
changed yeah over time yes absolutely is
stuff more expensive real estate being
one yeah yes like like we are not
denying that like of it is it is more
expensive but the problem I have with it
is is honest it's kind of it's kind of
his attitude of like oh my God versus
saying well I have $650 what can I do
now to better my life with that what do
we you know what I mean there's a
there's an attitude shift as well of how
you view this you can view it like eore
or you can view it like this is an
opportunity so what am I going to do
what am I going to do different how I
going to pay off debt so I can free up
an extra, a month yes how what am I what
are what's my opportunity here to do
what if I invested 300 of the
$350 every month from 22 to you know run
those numbers like like find the
opportunity in it I agree versus this
like well well you're you're all screwed
we're all just screwed I don't know what
we're going to do you know you're just
like oh my gosh like yeah they're
approaching it from the wrong angle it's
just like yeah that drives me crazy I
agree it's like oh must be nice like you
you're looking at it and like you said
he's $650 that's a lot of money oh
that's where I'm like listen I'm
standing on business that's $650 is a
lot of M talk what we what we do on the
show is talk to real people every single
day for three hours a day people are in
the red they don't have
$650 left over so and that's what I'm
saying the mindset if you if it's almost
like he's solving the wrong problem or
focusing on the wrong thing and not just
him cuz there's he he's speaking for
totally hundreds and you know thousands
and maybe millions of people this way
but if you're like you said If you're
looking at $650 that's not enough and
you're looking at um $400 and he's not
addressing that and he's not addressing
the the student loan it's just this is
the way it is there's nothing that's
going to change you're looking at the
wrong piece of the puzzle you've got to
look at I was listening to somebody
today that was saying that healthy
people um whether it's in a relationship
or just you as yourself you always look
at something and go okay what am I
contributing to this like if there's a
problem it's very easy to point out
there and say it's because of that that
that that and that but when you're um
healthy and have this area of maturity
you're always looking at it and going
what can I own in this situation Y and
if you're finding yourself even if it's
not a $74,000 budget that we're looking
at if you're looking at your own
finances and you just find yourself
feeling trapped blaming your job blaming
the fact that you have student loans
blaming your spouse you have to stop for
a moment and go okay wait a minute what
am I contributing to the situation cuz
here's the guarantee if there is
something that you're complaining about
in life I don't care what it is at this
point I'm beyond money if there's
something that you're complaining about
I guarantee I bet your bottom dollar
there's there's something that you are
doing that's contributing even if it's
slightly that you can tweak to make your
situation better and if you start to
turn the dial up on that and start
focusing on that that's going to point
to another thing that you can change and
you start focusing on that and that
points to another thing so it really
goes back to that idea of whatever ever
you're looking for that's what you find
so if you're looking for problems all
you find is problems if you look for
Solutions you're going to start to see
even if it's so small like Rachel you
just went through all of this like okay
like what would happen if you paid off
your car what would happen if you paid
off your student loan what would happen
and start asking yourself those
questions what can you contribute listen
it's a whole different equation at that
point I know and I do wonder you
mentioned it earlier but expectations
and this is something I always wrestle
with and it's and it it almost could be
just subconscious of what we just
naturally expect in our world cuz we're
so exposed to everyone's lifestyle I
mean whether it's like reality TV or
social media Instagram Tik Tok like you
see into people's lives more than any
other time in history yeah and you start
to see a glimpse and you start to expect
what you see you become numb to it
almost and it's like oh this is normal
and if I don't have that I'm not normal
I was talking to my mother-in-law
Christmas and she was like oh my God you
know she just made a comment how all
they did with their little kids at the
time they just all played in the
driveway and all the cold a get together
and now I'm like there's memberships to
things like there's all this stuff
that's normal but I'm like that wasn't
that's not that that doesn't have to be
nor yeah so it's just this like
subconscious expectation we have to
re-evaluate all the time and I think
it's really important to keep us
grounded in it because you can just
float off into this world spend a lot of
money that's
unnecessary and complain and do a Tik
Tok video that's a word Rachel that's a
word right there check out your
expectations figure out what's
motivating you is that the money
or is it an emotion that you're seeking
out this is the Ramsey Show create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life